You are listening to
radio lab radio from W.
N y. S. E. N. N. P. E. R.
So if we said where we
are, I'm untape yet, uh,
starting us off today are our
producers, Lynn Levy and Sean Cole,
very pretty day to be on an abandoned
island were victims of contagious disease
recording team. And one in particular who,
uh, lived here, died here,
never believing that she was
in fact sick and dangerous.
[inaudible]
so this is the story that she
begins with it. Well it's actually,
it starts in 1906 and it
doesn't start on the island.
It starts in Oyster Bay who,
nice neighbor, very nice.
There was this one rich family on vacation
there and their daughter gets sick.
She gets sick first. This is Judy Levitt.
I am a professor Emerita at the University
of Wisconsin and she wrote a book
about this story. So basically the girl,
the daughter has a fever than
her sister comes down with it.
And then her mom and Umaid about six
out of 11 in the family get sick.
And with this disease, the fever
is just the first part of it.
Both diarrhea or
constipation are reported.
So it can go either way. I
guess. What is it? Typhoid
and they couldn't figure out
what had caused the disease.
So they called in the sanitary engineer
named [inaudible] George Soper with the
public health department.
He was the go to guy for outbreaks like
this back then the department of public
health was thinking,
you know when you get sick because of
something dirty near you in in the well or
in the pipes. Yeah. So he
looks into all of that,
did a whole test on the house
and the water and everything.
Couldn't find anything.
And so he starts talking to the family
and he started quizzing them all and they
remember eventually in summer he
builds up this whole picture of,
of several outbreaks going back year
1900 Mamaroneck a New York family had a
house for the sun. 1902 dark harbor,
1904 seven cases, sands point,
New York, Autumn 1906 or 1907
New York City. All these cases.
And they all had one thing in common.
What each of these families had employed.
Same Cook,
which is funny because when you cook food,
you kill the bacteria in the food.
Yeah. So couldn't be the cook then.
But this cook, her most
famous dish was peach, Melba,
which is ice cream and fresh
peaches, fresh peaches,
raw fruit as a perfect
medium. And the Cook's name
was Mary Mallon, Mary Mary, Matt.
Wait a second. Shannon Cole, typhoid,
typhoid Mary. So we're talking about, oh,
so we know this store. No, you don't
know this story. What do you mean?
Everybody thinks they know this story? I,
I knew the story and then when I looked
into it I realized I didn't know the
first thing about it. And when
you look into the details,
they tell us some very difficult things
about who we were and who we still are.
In a lot of ways. It's all in the details.
All of the juice and probably, yeah,
like in like the, it's
like the PG juice. Yeah,
just like the peach juice still
dealing with it. I'm Robert Krulwich.
Go ahead. Go ahead. Right. Yeah. Boom.
Rod, this is Radiolab and in this hour,
a series of stories that all hew to
that delicious story archetype we call
patient zero.
The first clock we'll try to trace ideas
and trends and massive social traumas
like pandemics back to that one person
or one critter or the other week close
called the, but for if you
didn't have this thing,
but for this thing you wouldn't have
the rest of this. I like the button but,
but meanwhile, back to the peaches.
So you George Soper is like,
I've got to find this woman.
And when he finds her,
she's in New York City
working for another family.
The laundry's had recently been taken to
the Presbyterian hospital with typhoid
fever.
This is from an article super road called
the curious case of typhoid Mary and
the only child of the family, a
lovely daughter, was dying of it.
So he goes to the house, walks
into the kitchen, sees this woman,
five foot six blonde hair, blue eyes,
had a good figure and might've been
called athletic had she not been a little
too heavy. Irish immigrant, 36 years
old, not particularly clean. And he says,
Mary Mallon, I think you are causing
disease in people and I want,
uh, samples of your
urine, feces and blood.
Good afternoon. And she says, what
are you accusing me of being sick,
playing the role of Mary is Columbia
Public Health Professor David Rosner.
Oh dear you, I'm not a sick
person. What does she do?
She traces them out of the building
with that fork in her hand.
A serving fork. A surfing for it.
Yeah. I felt rather lucky to escape.
Did she have typhoid? Um, I mean,
did she outwardly have typhoid? Well,
that's the thing. She never had any
symptoms. She felt perfectly healthy.
She was actually the first documented
case in North America of a healthy
carrier,
which is to say someone
who has the disease and is
contagious but never actually
feels the symptoms, the
symptoms. So in one weird way,
sobers thrilled,
like he's only read about this and
then here she is in front of him.
But think of how all of this
must've sounded. The Mary, I mean,
some guy from outer space comes
into your kitchen and says,
you're diseased and you're hurting people.
When you, she must've thought what?
I feel fine. I'm living a moral life.
I'm not a vagrant. I'm employed.
I'm a good solid citizen. You know,
you would be crazy to what you're,
even today, you'd probably grab your
knife. Yeah, you grabbed your knife. Well,
does he have any evidence of that?
She is spreading the disease. Not yet.
That's why he needs her poop.
So he goes back and finds her at a
rooming house. She kicks him out,
swears at him. She apparently
had quite a temper.
And then the health department, uh,
sends in this female doctor by
the name of s Josephine Baker.
Maybe she could ask for blood feces
in urine. A little more gentle.
Please don't know how you
asked for that gently.
But she tries and when it doesn't work,
she comes back a little bit later with
cops and they come to the house and Mary
Mallon, when she realized is
what's happening, disappears.
May mean disappears,
completely vanishes.
They end up searching the entire
place and they can't find her.
Finally, I think they're about to leave.
When one of them spots her
skirt coming outside of a door.
It's a little piece of Calico high.
It kind of stuck in a doorway.
It opened the door and there she is
and so they drag her out and she comes
out kicking and screaming and screaming
and kicking. It takes all of
them to drag her out protesting.
They get her in the ambulance at Josephine
Bakers sits on her as according to
her, sits on her. And Baker
later said something like,
it was like being in a
cage with an angry lion.
So they take her down to the hospital.
They tested her pcs in urine
and they found that yes,
she was in fact a carrier
of live typhoid Bacilli
[inaudible].
So we're weird island man.
I spent a while on him.
So they isolate her and they
ultimately move her. Okay,
look for Manhattan too.
North brother island.
Let's have a bit of a haunted
bag. Yeah, and there she is.
Thanks man.
We went there to just to try to get our
heads around what she must have thought.
Let me think. What was the Allan Light
and everything is completely overgrown.
It was really creepy. Creepy because
it was in such dissolution. Yeah.
Yeah. Be careful where you step on one
end. There are all of these medical,
former medical buildings,
including a giant hospital where
they isolated tuberculosis patients.
So big brick, stately building. And
then on the other side of the island,
there's smaller wooden
buildings that are crushed.
Maybe where her cottages were,
her cottage would be if
it was still standing,
but it's not standing anymore.
Well, it was one room, one room.
Uh, I had a kitchen. It had a, I guess,
asleep sleeping area and a sitting area.
It probably so bad if you
didn't have to stay there.
You know, any places that you're not
free to leave of becomes like a prison.
So we're marching around and
then Lynn says to me, hey,
look at the view and holy Moly,
it's right there. That's when it really
hit me. If this is where her cabin was,
then one window of it looked
exactly on to Manhattan.
She could've seen where she used to live.
You can see the traffic on the streets.
This was like the most horrible seaside
vacation almost the whole time they had
her incarcerated, they took feces
three times a week, which is, you know,
it's not pleasant to have to do that. Um,
and sometimes she was negative and
sometimes she was positive. Wait, what?
So that's, that's another thing that
they were figuring out at the time.
So she was probably an intermittent
carrier. What does that mean?
The disease is always in her,
but sometimes she excretes it
and sometimes she doesn't. Oh,
that must've been confusing for her.
When I first came here, I was so nervous,
an almost prostrated with grief and
trouble. My eyes began to twitch.
This is from a letter that
Mary wrote from the island.
I have in fact been a peep show for
everybody. But if you keep reading it,
and in fact it's addressed to a lawyer,
it's clear that she was fighting this
and she had been sending her own feces,
samples herself to a
private lab in Manhattan.
And each one of those
was negative. Really.
The tuberculosis men would say
there she is the kidnapped woman.
Yeah. That is poison ivy.
She sees the city and loses still.
There are all these questions as to
whether any of this is legal. I mean,
even George Soper,
the guy who hunted her down said it
was contrary to the constitution of the
United States to hold her
under the circumstance.
And how long was she on the
silent? For? Three years. Wow.
And then what changed was a new
health commissioner took over.
And so he says it's just not right that
we keep a healthy woman locked up like
this. She was not dangerous to anybody.
If she didn't cook, he lets her go.
He lets you go back to Manhattan. But
he makes her promise. She did promise.
She signed an affidavit saying
she'll never cook again.
And she was released. They gave,
they've set her up with a job as a
laundress and they rent, here you go Mary.
And then, uh, you know, they
kept track of her for awhile.
Uh, and then at a certain point they
kind of stopped keeping track over.
So how many years will go by?
Five. Five. What happens next? A,
there's an outbreak of typhoid
where we're at a maternity hospital.
Oh, you're Josephine Baker,
who sat on her in the ambulance before.
She says that she goes and pays a visit
and walks into the kitchen and she says
the first person that she
encountered was typhoid Mary Mallon
[inaudible]
George Soper did some leg work on where
Mary had been and it turned out she had
worked at a restaurant,
two hotels and in and a sanatorium
as well as the hospital.
And at least according to his account,
two of the people that she
made sick during those couple
of years were children.
She was now a woman who
could not claim innocence.
She was known willfully and deliberately
to have taken desperate chances with
human life. She had abused her
privilege, she had broken her parole.
So then they put her back on north
brother island back in her bungalow. Um,
and there she sit.
She was a dangerous character
and must be treated accordingly.
Absolutely broke her
problem. I totally agree.
She made a deal and she didn't
keep the deal. But the thing is,
is that at the time she was
sent back to the island,
there were hundreds of other healthy
carriers identified all over New York,
and some of them were cooks. What
most really? Mostly men, by the way.
And they were cooking while
they were barred from cooking,
but not all of them always
listened. Huh. And yet,
Mary was the only one who they
isolated in this way. Why?
Why only her?
I think it was more about making people
feel safe than actually making them say,
oh, look out for the stare. Saul crumbled.
She was what we needed at the time
were in the hospital where the
tuberculosis patients were quarantined.
This was towards the end of
linen. My visit to the island.
Yeah. These must be the words. Yeah.
So when was she here?
This is where they brought
her after she had a stroke.
And this is where she was for
the last six years of her life.
Did she die in here? Yeah.